[Music]
I would like to talk briefly about
depolarization on the left and the right
because I think there's a technical
problem that needs to be addressed so
here's what I've been thinking about
it's been obvious to me for some time
that for some reason the fundamental
claim of post-modernism is something
like an infinite number of
interpretations and no canonical
overarching narrative okay but the
problem with that is okay now what no
narrative no value structure that's
canonical or overarching so what the
hell are you gonna do with yourself how
are you gonna orient yourself in the
world well the post modernist have no
answer to that so what happens is they
default without any real attempt to
grapple with the cognitive dissonance
they default to this kind of this this
loose egalitarianism egalitarian Marxism
and it if they were concerned with
coherence that would be a problem but
since they're not concerned with
coherence it doesn't seem to be a
problem but the force that's driving the
activism is mostly the Marxism rather
than the post-modernism it's more like a
an intellectual gloss to hide the fact
that a discredited economic theory is
being used to what fuel and educational
movement and to produce activists so but
there's no coherence to it but I mean
like it's not like I'm making this up
you know
Derrida himself regarded and at Foucault
as well they were barely repentant
Marxists they were they were part of the
student revolutions in France in the
1960s and what happened to them
essentially and what happened to Jean
Paul Sartre for that matter was that by
the end of the 1960's you couldn't be
conscious and thinking and Pro Marxist
there's so much evidence that had come
pouring in from the former Soviet Union
from the Soviet Union at that point and
from Mao's China of the absolutely
devastating consequences of the doctrine
that it was impossible to be apologetic
for it by that point in time so the
French intellectuals in particular just
pulled off a sleight of hand and
transformed Marxism into post modern
identity politics
and like we've seen the consequence of
that it's not good it's a devolution
into a kind of tribalism that's well
that's gonna that will that will tear us
apart on the right and on the left and
on the right a guy in my in my house I
have a very large collection of
Socialist Realist paintings from the
former Soviet Union propaganda pieces
but also kind of harsh
impressionist pieces of working-class
people and so forth and I collected them
for a variety of reasons
now you could debate about the propriety
of that given the murderous nough subs
and fair enough
I have my reasons but I don't have
paintings from the Nazi area era in my
house and I wouldn't and that's been a
puzzlement to me because I regard the
Communists the totalitarian communist
regimes as just as murderous as the Nazi
regimes but there's an evil associated
with the Nazi regime that seems more
palpable in some sense so I've been
thinking about that for a long time and
then I've been thinking about a
corollary to that which is part of the
problem with our current political
debate so on the right I think we've
identified markers for people who've
gone too far in their ideological
presuppositions and it looks to be like
the marker we've identified is racial
superiority and I think we've known that
probably since the end of World War two
but we saw a pretty good example of it
in the 1960s with William Buckley
because Buckley when he put out his his
conservative magazine the David Duke
type types kind of attached themselves
to it and he said no here's the boundary
you guys are on the wrong side of the
boundary I'm not with you and ben
shapiro recently did this for for
example as well in the aftermath of the
Charlottesville incident so the so
what's interesting is that on the
conservative side of the spectrum we've
figured out how to box in the radicals
and say no you're outside the domain of
acceptable opinion now here's the issue
we know that things can go far too far
on the right and we know that things can
go too far on the left but we don't know
what the markers are for going too far
on the left and I would say that it's
ethically incumbent on those who are
liberal or left-leaning to identify the
markers of pathological extremism on the
left and to distinguish themselves from
the people who hold those pathological
viewpoints and I don't see that that's
being done and I think that's a that's a
colossal ethical failure and it may do
the liberal left project like the
lefties have their point there they're
driven fundamentally by a horror of
inequality and the catastrophes that
inequality produces and fair enough
because inequality is a massive social
force and it does produce it can produce
catastrophic consequences so to be
concerned about that politically is
reasonable but we do know that that
concern can go too far okay so I've
suggested that there's a triumvirate of
concepts that bear the same that what
would you say have the same potentially
catastrophic outcomes when implemented
as the racial superiority doctrines
diversity inclusivity and equity as a
triumvirate even though you can have an
intelligent conversation about two of
those anyways but I would say that of
the three equity is the most
unacceptable the doctrine of equality of
outcome and it seems to me that that's
where people who are thoughtful on the
Left should draw the line say no quality
of opportunity not only fair enough but
laudable but equality of outcomes like
nope you've you've crossed the line
we're not going there with you now maybe
that's wrong maybe it's not equity
that's my candidate for it but it is
definitely the case that you can go too
far on the left and it's definitely the
case that we don't know where to draw
the line and that's a big problem well
an example of equality of outcome is
attempts being made now to to implement
the legislative necessity to eliminate
the gender pay gap that's a good example
I mean you think well no that's not like
there's nothing pathological about that
it's like oh yes there is
you have to set up a bureaucratic
Inquisition to ensure that that's the
case it's like it's not good and that's
actually a relatively like of all the
things that you could push for with
regards to equality of outcome that's
right rather simple and definable it's
not even murky once it starts to get
murky it's just complex beyond any
rectification you cannot win if you play
identity politics there's a bunch of
reason it's like here's one let's push
for equality of outcome all right who
measures it that's a big problem it's
not a little problem it's not like we'll
figure that out later oh no no no the
measurement problem is paramount so you
don't solve that you don't solve the
problem at all who measured it a
bureaucracy okay which bureaucracy well
a large one that has its fingers
everywhere okay that's problem number
one and it's staffed by exactly the sort
of people that you don't want to staff
it by the way next problem which
identities
that's the intersectional problem right
the the radical leftists have already
hit the problem of intersectionality
it's like well we've got race and gender
let's say well okay what about the
intersection between race and gender
that's a multiplicative intersection
right so you might start with three
racial categories and two gender
categories but you end up with six
intersectional categories and then
you're just getting started how many
genders hypothetically there's an
infinite number what about racial
groupings you can include ethnicity you
want to add class to that you want to
add socio-economic class
how about attractiveness and every time
you add another category to this to the
singular entities you increase the
multiplicative end entities in a
multiplicative fashion what are you
gonna do you're gonna equate across all
those categories really and and across
what dimensions what are the dimensions
of equality that you want to establish
it's just socio-economic is it's just
salary what about all the other ways
that people are unequal you just start
with economic inequality are you it's
like it's a complete bloody
Astra fee it's an absolute mess and
intersectionality the discovery of
intersectionality on the left is
actually the radical left's discovery of
the fundamental flaw in their identity
politics ideology groups can be
multiplied without limit okay that's not
a problem that's a fatal flaw
and they've already discovered it they
just haven't figured it out the reason
that the west privileges the individual
is because we figured out 2,000 years
ago three thousand years ago that you
can fraction eight group identity
appropriately right down to the level of
the individual
[Music]